I am thrilled to introduce the lifelong
Explorer evolutionary biologist and
two-time Pulitzer Prize winner professor
Edward o Wilson
[Applause]
okay I certainly very grateful I feel
honored to be invited by to give this
lecture at this world science festival
and I'm grateful to you for joining me
here now Paul Gauguin's in Paul
Gauguin's 1898 masterpiece he never
painted me here we are
Tahitian masterpiece which he intended
to be his last work before committing
suicide he didn't he went on up with
arsenic he'd piled up sufficient lethal
dose to take with him and went to the
mountain was in order to hide himself so
that he would be tanned my aunt she said
before he'd been so he was found but he
didn't he came back and went on painting
but not by very much and then looking
for more solitude and more salt so he
went out to the farthest were corner of
the world of Marquesas where he did in
fact not commit suicide but he did die
but he gave him title in the supper in
leper in left-hand corner as you see it
these famous questions where do we come
from
what are we and where are we going now
these happen to be the three central
questions of religion and philosophy
through millennia we thought and argued
about the first of these two questions
where do we come from and what are we
will we ever be able to solve them
sometimes it seems not yet maybe we can
religion will never provide the answers
the reason is that each organized
religion and there are hundreds of them
has its own different creation story in
competition with all the others each
creation story was written in times when
circumstances when the author's knew
almost nothing
about the universe the planet life on
Earth or the prehistory of the human
condition
each considers its creation story and
answer to where do we come from and what
are we and where are we going to be set
in stone and superior to all the others
each was born from the dreams and
speculations of shamans and prophets
they can't all be correct no two can be
correct in fact none is consistent with
our growing knowledge of the universal
planet life on Earth and the prehistory
of the human condition we also look in
vain to philosophy for the answer to the
great riddle passe my fellow colleagues
my colleagues in philosophy
despite its normal purpose noble
partners
despite its effectiveness in training
the mind to inquire and think logically
professional secular philosophy long ago
gave up trying to answer the overall
question what is the meaning of life
most of the history of philosophy is
strewn with the wreckage of theories of
the conscious mind after the decline of
logical positivism in the middle of the
last century and the attempt to join
science and logic into a closed system
philosophers have scattered in an
intellectual diaspora into those areas
not yet colonized by science into
intellectual history cymatics logic
foundational mathematics ethics and most
profitably problems of personal life
adjustment by default in the solution of
the great riddle has been left to
science to knowledge of the real world
it can be tested and shared with every
person what Sciences promises and has
already supplied in part is the
following there is a real creation story
of humanity and one only and it isn't a
myth it's being worked out and tested
and enriched and strengthened
step-by-step what I'm a talent I'll
attempt to show you today
is to tell you that story as I believe
it's coming into focus it comes together
from multiple disciplines from molecular
genetics the neuroscience evolutionary
biology to ecology archaeology
paleoanthropology social psychology and
history to make that effort let me first
define the very high level of social
complexity we call you sociality EU
meaning little originally agreeable or
peaceful but we mean really that really
social highly social it is the existence
of groups over multiple generations in
which adult members rear the young
cooperatively and very their own
longevity or reproduction or both in
ways that enhances the complexity of
social organization there are countless
thousands of animal species that form
social groups and some are dramatic like
the gorilla troop here especially the
chimpanzee but almost all like gorillas
and chimpanzees fall short of
eusociality
they lack a consistent division of
reproduction and labor in fact true
sociology sociality has originated on
the terrestrial part of the planet only
very relased rarely and here I'm going
to bring in I believe for the first time
into these discussions Comparative
Zoology which I feel is critical to the
solution of the problem of the origin of
the human condition it's come into
existence to the best of my knowledge
eusociality has been about two dozen
times of what which we have record
variously in several kinds of insects
twice in the mole-rats of africa once in
the human line it didn't happen at all
until quite late in evolutionary time
from the early measles though
that's how far back the first cases we
know of it goes about 150 million years
ago
and finally and strikingly it is in this
very small array of evolutionary lines
that the numerically most abundant and
ecologically dominant creatures on earth
are found advanced social animals rule
the land in many habitats of the world
for example rainforest and African
savanna uh ants I've just come back
three days ago from the African savanna
if I say something that sounds dopey you
will of course forgive me from jet lag
but any rate we find that the ants alone
outweigh all of the land vertebrates
together four times for example in the
molting beak savanna where I was working
ants and termites together are weigh
approximately 100 kilograms per hectare
and that's more considerably more than
all of the mammals birds reptiles and
amphibians combined this is the setting
we need to address in order to
understand the origin of humanity and
here are the more basic questions more
than even what it all means and how it
originated in humans the biologists and
anthropologists have not yet addressed
first question why does advanced social
life exist at all and why has it
occurred so rarely why given that the
condition is so enormous ly successful
for example or to wit the social use
social insects ants bees wasp termites
have a comprise only about two this
3% of all the only species of insects on
earth yet in most habitats they weigh
more than 50% of they have more than 50%
of all of the inside biomass and the
second question what is the driving
force in evolution that brought you
sociality this quite rare condition into
existence the first great evolutionary
wave of insects was 400 million years -
250 million years ago and came to a
crashing in like so much of the
diversity of life was the end of the
Permian period during this time of 150
million years there was an exuberant
evolution among insects some of the
presently existing orders of insects
like beetles and may flies and
cockroaches first originated there but
then also a great diversity of other
kinds of insects with names like ume
caprara paleo dip dioptre fruit
Orthoptera and so on and on names that
you will have already promptly forgotten
had you been listening ah became extinct
and out of that great diversity which
one insect paleontologist has very
nicely puzzled out as occupying
different niches on the cold forest
trees out of that vast array rivaling
what was to follow in our own time no
sign of eusociality occurred in the
insects or other invertebrates it simply
hadn't happened yet the first ants and
termites appeared around 150 million
years ago early Jurassic butt in the
measles oeq there was still no eusocial
vertebrate in spite of anatomically
likely candidates there were reptiles of
great variety and even early mammals but
of eusociality not
and to illustrate what the potential was
I've now used the example of one of the
bipedal dinosaurs with hands and the
brain actually we don't know what the
capacity of a reptile brain would be in
the course of evolution but surely
enough for the kind of advanced part
weight that actually brought us into
existence over the last two million
years so I've used the diagram made by
another a paleontologist of the
dinosauroid of what it might look like
and this occasion happened but it didn't
now to explain what happened or better
almost didn't happen let me offer the
metaphor of the evolutionary maize
species proceeded through the maze step
by step all species - it's inevitable
led by the action of natural selection
generation by generation on the genomes
they possess in each instance of time
they can move in one direction or
another as metaphors in this maze they
can stall for a while they can even
regress it is a matter of luck enabled
by mutation driven by natural selection
to reach any point in that maze and that
is achieved by a series of particular
steps each of which may or may not take
place if we look retrospectively at the
result in which we are interested in
this case eusociality from say solitary
Hamunaptra net ancestors the upper
left-hand corner through all the steps
in that maze finally to come out with a
youth social species then then we can
speak of these essentially random tree
adaptations and there is a final step
the lower right-hand corner whatever it
is from solitary or elementary group to
use sociality what is that final step
it is in all of the two dozen cases of
which I have had found record and have
been able to study it is in all of them
ah the rearing of young in a valuable
constructed nest defended from which
individuals forage for food returned
with it to give to the young growing
progressively until they reach maturity
that's it everyone no exception of the
two dozen cases reach eusociality that
way so the question is did humans more
of that in a moment but just for example
here we have at the top of your social
shrimp marine shrimp it fits that
there's a queen in the middle there
nesting and burrows built-in sponges and
those are young all around defending the
nest and going out to forage for food on
the right elected bees among the most
primitive Lea your social insects we
know and here burrows are built nest
chambers constructed and there's a queen
very early stages of evolution and
workers very similar and anatomically
and behaviorally otherwise for the Queen
go forth forage for food altruistically
bring it raise brothers and sisters then
we have vast numbers of cases and this
is what they're instructive sort of like
a evolutionarily controlled experiment
like the one of these arrow killing
beetles here in which there are
societies in this case that's the young
being led along and heard carefully
tended herd by the adults and of all
these cases we know call sub sociality
not a single one in the phylogeny or
even in the infer
a inferred proceeding stage of truths
ago sociality not one has ever gone on
to use sociality the thing they lack a
defended nest from which some
individuals go forth to bring food to
bring back to the young and feed them
until they reach maturity quite a few
species of animals are at the threshold
chimpanzees and gorillas for example is
shown here the African wild dog which is
almost but not quite you social and many
many so sub social insects as I've said
would just get there but they don't
cross if they haven't taken the final
step and they really haven't gone very
very far there and they're successful
but they're just another species in the
ecosystem now I'm going to use recent
primary research literature I've
depended almost entirely on that rather
than the interpretations of others are
even well I have used in some cases
authoritative reviews to trace the steps
as best I can understand them in other
words those pre propitious pre
adaptations that led from the split
between the Huey pre human and
chimpanzee lines some six million years
ago now this is what I'm about to show
you and then try to identify the point
at which humans became you social in a
broad sense it's the synthesis of a
great deal of work by many gifted
scientists around the world and I wish
they could all be listed but this is not
my work there was brilliant work that
has been achieved in this area and is in
fact multiplying now the first step was
to come out of the trees and walk on
hind legs and Shemp have done both of
these but their walk is not a wreck it
is knuckle walking essentially still
four footed
they're bipedal they use tools they have
cultures which are particular to two
individuals localities and populations
and obviously passed down from one
generation to the next stone trowing
swimming or entering water ah termite
fishing one in each population and so on
ah but that's it
it's very very limited the habitat
however this is the foot of some
interest the habitats in which three
humans evolved was the African savannah
the biome that ranges from tree dotted
glass land to open dry seasonal forests
as I've said I've just returned from
doing research there and I'm so very
impressed to actually be one of the 102
mammal species native to Mozambique that
are on the checklist from the Gorongosa
National Park I like to remind people
that as we go out we see a honey bee
nest up in a bail Bob tree I say that
species apis mellifera that's up in that
tree is native to here and we or natives
we are uh native species now at the time
of the breakout sixty thousand years ago
approximately people were living pretty
much like the Kong Sun of the Kalahari
as shown here but now we have to go back
to connect them with the most primitive
forms of pre humans that have been
tracked that gives us a sense of the
steps leading up to you if I'm not
overusing the word
to the event of eusociality in humans
4.4
years ago we have remains of something
called art of Pittacus it had obviously
come out of the trees that part in part
it has long arms presumably it could
still brachiate in the trees but it
walked on legs straight it was straight
up walking also are it and it's
immediate the descendants had one great
advantage which I will call a pre
adaptation but it's almost four it's not
fortuitous it was essential and that is
the primate condition of fingers that
have pulpy tips flat nails the capacity
to create a gripping organ is organ and
even eventually an opposable thumb and
that made all the difference in these
newly erect creatures in being their
ancestors had it and their ancestors
used it to pick fruit vegetable material
with precision
you know like pulling seeds out what
peeling things so on
that was their adaptation and that was
to be a vital human trait within a
million years what may have been our two
Pittacus or as you know as a direct
ancestor we don't have enough
information to know whether how many
species there were whether this that
creature was on the main line but
something like it probably was close or
was the actual ancestor now we have the
australopithecines and they have taken a
very important step forward based
largely on their bipedalism and we find
now that the arms of shorten that not
only
the legs but the feet have elongated
giving the creature a walking of rocking
foot motion and it's developed a basin
shaped pelvis into which the internal
organs of a fully bipedal organ rest
with with minimum energy energy expense
and and deficiency there was an adaptive
radiation going on this is a pretty
successful group in terms of species the
australopithecines are multiplied in
species across Africa there were at one
time at least three coexisting in this
on the African continent
primarily the East African region and
these were specialized among them for
praten doubtedly for vegetable food of
different types the skull varied in
massiveness for lack of it grassle
versus massive probably having to do
with dealing with different kinds of
vegetables of variable toughness from
one of these species of the australopith
radiation an evolutionary line evolved
that listed not just australopith not
just all world primates and mammals but
all of life to an entirely new level it
occurred beginning about three million
years ago and was manifested in the
dramatic increase in brain size
particularly the memory storing regions
of the cortex prior to this time the pre
human brain size at for hundreds of
fifty five hundred cubic centimeters was
not much above the size of a chimp if et
had arrived and made the survey of life
on Earth
and sent the report back and then left
this interesting but unspectacular
planet from all the ones they've seen it
would said it's observing australopiths
it said an interesting primate
development but the really interesting
thing on this planet is the amazing
social insects see volume 3 through 16
I admit that that's a partisan review
but I suspect that really would be the
case but now all of that changes the
brain size increases dramatically at
what was quite possibly the fastest rate
for a complex organ ever what was going
on and now we come to the sticking point
where I admit this is a guess but what
was going on the crucial event occurred
at about the time of the one of these
australopith species arising or
developing with a brain size that was
about 640 cubic centimeter that's Homo
habilis about I wish we knew more but
what happened to the home to the hable
eyes was that they shifted from
vegetarian food like chimps which has I
think get 3 percent of their calories
from hunting killing vervets and a few
prey whereas humans get 10 times their
amount over average over all
hunter-gatherer societies the have a
line they shifted to a greater
consumption of meat now very likely they
had been following a feeding on small
animals already as do chimps today I've
said but in addition at best guessed
they shifted reliance to animals of all
sizes and they could have been animals
collected after lightning struck ground
fires well you live for a while in these
savanna
environments as I have including the
southern United States which is
primarily the longleaf pine savanna 60%
of it then you are very impressed at how
rapidly ground fires occur from
lightning strikes and if it's a
well-balanced biodiverse environment
that allows these lightning struck fires
that they can proceed in these frequent
intervals then you keep that environment
stable me if you can get it is
energetically more efficient per gram
and cooked meat which was available to
these creatures as fire killed is the
easiest ax to just eaten you just
matters an idea not original with me but
it has gained some currency for this
stage of evolution among
paleoanthropologist what began as the
runaway growth of brain size was not
just the consumption of meat however it
was the way meat is harvested animals
that live in groups and hunt typically
do so from dens from strongholds as in
wild dogs and wolves or some stay to
protect the young almost by necessity
while others hunt for prey and scavenge
meat to bring home and if they can bring
down the prey then they have enough
calorific food calories in food to serve
the entire group so right about here in
other words three to two million years
ago pre humans created campsites they
began using if you permit me protected
nest where offspring could be raised
progressively in other words they came
and passed over the threshold to use
sociality just as in all other known
species of animals that breach and cross
the threshold for which we can
confidently reconstruct the event and
once again let me repeat that
outside of humans every case without
exception that we've tracked
phylogenetically
Sene thinking we can do this with
insects because we have huge numbers of
species in almost every major group we
can make inferences not possible with
vertebrate everyone went this pathway
but then what is going on when you live
in close contact in the same place when
you no longer travel around in loose
groups searching for fruit and other
vegetable food transmitting a messages
back and forth that you found something
or not found something let's do the
chimps when you divide labor then the
reading of intention becomes vital
understanding from body language and
facial expression and vocalizations what
other people think and won't and from
that you develop cooperation based on
social intelligence social intelligence
is the key and here I speak not for
myself I think I speak for a large
number of cognitive psychologists who
are beginning to see the human condition
one of the fundamental traits of human
conditions along with group conflict is
that by the time of Homo erectus
descendants of the habit land is most
likely and direct ancestors of our own
species
almost certainly Homo sapiens campsite
or well-developed fire had been
controlled at the campsite and stone
tools had been adopted brain size was
significantly a creased increased over
that of the javelina halfway to the
erectus level by 60,000 years ago Homo
sapiens were fully evolved into our
present form and the breakout from that
Africa occurred most likely up to now
corridor followed by rapid spread
through population growth all the way to
Australia the physical appearance and
early culture of these pioneers is
preserved at least in part in a few
places mabuki pygmies of the congo the
little Andaman these pygmies of North
who's on the people of New Guinea and
Australia now to the next key question I
proposed what drove one of the several
pre-human australopithecine lines of the
eusocial threshold it was almost
certainly group selection and here I
depart from a lot of colleagues to their
discomfort as William James Muntz said
history is a bloodbath and we know that
was the case very early in human history
in prehistory what we looked we've
looked on as an extreme aggressiveness
in the yanomamö have I got them up there
yet yep wonderful people of northern
South America and other warlike people
have been true of our own societies
whether periodically or even
continuously almost uniformly vengeance
raids were succeeded by organized
divinely sanctioned war and so vividly
and proudly shown by the Mayans and
other chieftains and early states around
the world during and following their
evolution from the best evidence we have
in damage skeletons and cave paintings
raids battles were common all the way
back into the Paleolithic these are you
know there's a lot more to cave art than
just beautiful animals it's full of
interesting graffiti some of which is
still not proper for a mixed company and
also for scenes such as these which show
unquestionably people getting killed
with spear thrust now let me remind you
of the basic process of individual level
natural selection with an imaginary
shift of say plumage color just to make
it the elementary part clear
before returning to group selection
there are two competing aliens in this
ultra-simple at felon different forms of
the same gene the tray prescribed by one
of the alleles for dark blue results in
a higher genetic fitness meaning greater
longevity reproductive performance for
both over a number of generation to dark
blue allele replaces the competing light
blue allele individual selection of
genetic traits occurs when members of
the same group when we're in an early
stage of group evolution when members of
this group compete with members of the
same group individual selections
occurring group selection occurs when
groups compete on with other groups on
the basis of interactions of social
individuals within each group and here
is what's important this distinction
contrary to an enormous amount of
confusion in the literature trying to
solve these problems semantically this
distinction between individual and group
selection the two together called
multi-level selection is open to precise
genetic analysis simply by the two-part
classification of the traits that is the
phenotypes the phenotypic targets of the
group selected traits are the inherited
forms of interaction among members of
the same group including communication
dominance procedures cooperation now
it's rare in evolution as I've as I've
stressed I'm not sure what's coming next
anyway let me go on
oh yeah we're stopping here I asked if
we stopped here because I don't want to
confuse you with another subject which
if I had time I would cover but I'm
gonna leave it off as to how this
translates into different aspects of
human culture any rate if it's rare and
evolution as I've stressed the group
selection proof
Vail's over individual selection now
this is a phenomenon because of the
rarity of the origin of eusociality
prima facie ah that we need to think
about so it's not too hard to have a
mutation that silences shall we say the
dispersal tendencies of group of
offspring with it was a pair a mating
pair or small group one mutation was do
that there's a silence and especially so
why hasn't it gone on well group
selection has a tough time apparently
prevailing over individual level
solution selection creating altruism and
new social societies it happens through
the following balance I believe of
individual selection and group selection
within groups and this is an
overstatement but nevertheless the idea
I want to convey within groups selfish
individuals beat altruistic individual
but groups of altruists beat groups of
selfish individuals that is sin if you
please is favored by individual
selection and virtue if you please is
favored by group selection the conflict
between individual selection and group
selection is unstable in genetic
evolution that instability and the
conflicted nature of the human mind is
responsible for a large part of the
content of the humanities now before I'd
have generate too much rage among you I
will pass on quickly those who have
followed recent literature and
evolutionary theory will recognize at
this account of the driving force
multi-level selection with the emphasis
on group selection that's the key is
that variance with a traditional theory
of the evolution of altruistic behavior
and eusociality by kin selection and a
supposed product the measure of
inclusive fitness now I certainly
embrace that when it first came out 40
years ago but things have changed
more evidence here so two years ago
including the material I've just gone
through with you two years ago two
mathematicians of the first rank now
I'll make that statement that sweeping
statement of the first rank martin novak
and karina carnita because the the
problem the mathematical problem of
taking the hamilton inequality all the
way down who is foundation with all the
assumptions and all the possibilities
that's a difficult mathematical problem
but this has been solved by them and we
know it's been solved when we brought
our paper ready
it was sense of nature and to anyone who
says but I think as a couple of
commentators have said maybe it's
because the prestige of Harvard resulted
in nature publishing a paper let me
assure you nature sent an editor to have
a conference with us
and we went through the entire thing
with the nature editor before they
submitted it to very strict peer review
I can tell you and I know that the
mathematical analysis of the Hamilton
inequality performed by Novak and
tornado is correct I'm not a
mathematician but it has been worked
through repeatedly by one mathematician
who recently said it's too beautiful not
to be true well we've heard that too but
that's nice anyway that is well it
showed that the basic assumptions of
inclusive fitness theory are
mathematically unsound I could spell out
why it's mathematically unsound and
second and this is my contribution the
equally good or superior biological
explanations for behavior previously
ascribed to Ken's election are available
other explanations are available for
multi-level selection and tailing
individual level selection alone or a
Nadder interaction with group selection
now I've tested every case that I can
find in the literature on that
and found this that I could demonstrate
this that multi-level selection is the
one that's most comprehensive most
clear-cut and in my mind most feasible I
even put down recently with experts on
one of the favorite examples that of
helper at the nest of birds and I
actually went through all of the
evidence for one hypothesis as to
another with the researchers working on
it and with the birds in the field I was
there anyway our arguments have created
a lot of spirited defense of kin
selection theory but none to my
knowledge has addressed what we pointed
out in not 2010 are the fatal flaws at
its foundation now I've covered this
subject in considerable depth in my book
the social conquest of the earth and if
interested you can pursue the subject
there and also in Martin Novak's recent
book super co-operators I'm running out
of time so I was now some of them in any
case if we are right and I'm confident
on this issue we are right the door is
now fully open for a fuller examination
that has been possible of the biological
origins of our profoundly conflicted
human nature the overall perception of
the origin of the human condition of
this kind
I believe throws light on subjects in
the social sciences and humanities
previously unconnected in this way to
biological research the origins of
culture language morality religion the
creative arts of the kind in many cases
already well underway connections of
this kind by scholars in various fields
it also offers promise that the three
great and now I'm reaching the three
great branches of learning the Natural
Sciences the social sciences
the humanities will be linked in a new
and interesting manner thank you very
much yeah okay thank you
I'm making thank you so much I'm making
mental note those not purporting to
recognize can do you know loyalist of
kin selection I didn't see any but I
have time we have time for several
questions and I'd be very happy to
entertain them now
questions comments would it be logical
then to say that communities imposed
laws on the individual as they try to
survive
amongst other communities absolutely yes
you know in our obedience to laws to
more age to our rules there is a
conservative streak in us is inherited
probably I'm just guessing but this is
speculation but for has in has evolved
with very good purpose you know for
resolution and the ability for a group
to unite particularly under stress yep
hi could you talk a little bit about the
break from when pre humans went from not
conscious of themselves in the
environment to where they began to
perceive themselves as separate from the
environment if I could answer the
question of how people have managed to
create a culture and a way of the whole
worldview in a way of thinking that
separates them from the rest of the
environment I would publish it here with
as a matter of fact I've I have tried to
do that in a series of books including
one called bio phillium and I do have a
book forthcoming aha please if there's a
representative of WW Norton presence
make note that I'm doing the job here I
hope next year called Lauren goes on a
window on her eternity in which I
present the history the nature of
Gorongosa National Park almost destroyed
by the civil war of 1997 t-62 92 and
which is being revived now I'm an
advisor for this in Mozambique ah and it
was a good place to try to answer that
question just
that what is there about human humans
that make us almost dream you know I'm
unstoppable
in our reckless destruction actually of
the rest of life that's what we're doing
around the world we're destroying the
rest of life but don't get me started
this is a key question that I think
ought to be examined in a more distant
and and logical way to make it more
convincing the moral argument work of
benching you know sorry over here I
wonder you might speculate on the
situation with the small-tooth marine
mammals for example which display almost
all of the you social characteristics
you went over with the exception of the
defense of a den which seems somehow we
were relevant in an aquatic environment
including the large brain growth yeah I
actually that's a very good question
because we have virtually we have only
the African mole rats for the small
mammals as eusocial and it is a fact
that lots of mammals have nest and they
go out they and get food and bring it to
the young and birds do all trishal birds
all our official bird species virtually
build a nest and they go out and so why
haven't we had a any eusocial birds
particularly now I don't want to ignore
this and say oh that's nothing I said
could be construed as negative evidence
of what I've just said but thinking back
to our two piscis and to the fundamental
primate trait I think it has a lot to do
with the fact that birds operate with
beaks and claws they just didn't have
that pre adaptation and I'd like to say
to any future authors of science fiction
alien invasion movies that please have
the aliens with pulpy fingers
not not claws or fangs you're gonna have
to make them that as we sat through that
degree humanoid oh yeah
I'd like to give a s let Harrell have a
question because if I'm gonna get a
tough question I want to get it over
with now okay but all of us have been
involved in scientific disputes
tent-like to think about the experiment
or the evidence that would silence our
critics or silence ourselves so when you
think about what might destroy those who
hold two kin selection or when you think
about how your you yourself might change
your mind
what are the pieces of evidence that you
think difficult though they might be to
obtain would mate would be decisive in
these arguments yeah I think that's a
fair question and this is after all a
science festival I mean science right
okay the I think I did touch on what
destroyed they in my view of the kin
selection
you know nothing radical just proof of
the function the better explanations
alternative explanation what would
destroy the thesis I'm giving you I
think the most vulnerable area is
paleoanthropology and the details worked
out in timing and ecology is which
paleoanthropologists are moving rapidly
to fill in and if it doesn't fit it
seems to and the broadest terms now but
if that doesn't fit if something is
discordant there we'll have to think
again but I think in the case of social
insects we are on very solid grounds
because we have lots and lots of studies
and you know total with phylogeny z' and
total lifecycle studies and so on and
and the other reason that I hesitate
about offering vulnerability as I hate
to think about it
you understand okay actually two
questions one might be a little too
complicated it was what are we gonna do
with this new mathematical understanding
that you're so sure of but I think a
more interesting question for this group
is where are we going to be as a human
species let's say millions of years from
now provided that our earth is still
intact well you know I avoided the
question of the third question of mr.
Gong Gong where are we going and you are
a person I know that thinks a lot about
that question of where we're going
especially when that moment comes red
over coffee and scrambled eggs on the
front page of the New York Times when
the first rock planet proves to have
just equilibrium gas envelope and
therefore it looks as though life still
exists elsewhere and so but I'm getting
off the track what are we going to do
I mean where do I think we'll be how not
long from now you you can pick a number
in the future that you all don't see
millions of years 50 years because look
science and technology is a fact that's
doubling every 10 to 20 years depending
on discipline and that's been the case
incidentally since the 17th century I
mean we've just been going up you know
now we're we're like that and who can
predict what we're going to find out
what new technologies will apply to even
to subjects like the one I've been
talking about it's just impossible so I
picked the last chapter in my book where
are we going to say admittedly biased
where we probably won't want to go and
one of them is to take our poor real
primate perfect earth adapted bodies
into space to colonize someplace after
we've used up this planet to me that's
all
worst idea I ever heard so I think we're
gonna stay put and so we really almost
have to turn this planet into the
livable home there should be and our
bodies after all you know we are adapted
to this planet in every aspect of our
physiology our Anatomy our mental state
I mean why should we want to leave the
other thing has to do with your
specialty and as if we find the key what
are they gonna be like are there gonna
be hostile you know I think that if what
I've just laid out or promoting turns
out to be valid there's a general theory
we can save this much they're gonna have
puppies flat nails and that they are
going to be conflicted as we are because
that you know I it's happened in 24 two
dozen or so times independently over now
it mounts to you know 150 million years
always the same way in very different
environment maybe just thinking you know
just guessing maybe that's the way it
always happens regardless of all the
environment just a thought yeah so so
you've been doing where are we going but
I'm going to ask another sort of type of
question about time which has been very
interesting to me for a long time and
touches upon these notions of
eusociality that you've discussed and
this is basically of the creatures that
display eusociality and also I guess the
time timeline of human evolution at some
point the notion and sensitivity to time
and the understanding of the world not
just in spatial terms but also in
temporal terms was one of the main main
advances of our of our society and my
question is how does that play into the
criteria of eusociality and does that
play a role in other of the
the creatures that display this you know
well I devoted Lilith time I had here
today to the genetics you know the
genetic base and the general trend but
then it's an entirely new set of
problems or questions to be discussed in
fact they are among the classical
questions of of evolutionary studies is
how did culture originated and what
impacted culture have on the genetic
determinants of behavior in social
behavior in humans you know what is
their instinct and so on i unless
tracy will try to persuade the audience
to stay in another hour i'm not going to
enter into that but i do say that in the
book i put a lot of time into that and I
do have chapters on what I think is the
best answer that's possible for how
culture originated what it is exactly
you know having to do with the
flexibility of phenotypes and so on
how it has evolved co-evolved with
genetic evolution in the process called
gene-culture co-evolution an entire
field of inquiry which is still largely
uninvestigated either by theory or by
instructed experimental empirical
research and so on there and then taking
it into things like the origin of
morality of the creative arts and so on
this is where I'd love to at least watch
as a spectator if the subject holds up I
mean this whole approach holds up this
is a whole new domain but it doesn't
change in my mind the importance of the
humans the pre humans going through the
same bottleneck to the final stage of
your sociality that's apparently the
rest of advanced social creatures went
through one more yes
Oh my former student Mark had been
giving me causing me trouble in various
categories for some years what are you
doing what are you doing out of the
rainforest ed just just curious uh
you've always said that if you were
starting your career now you'd be become
a microbiologist I think yes I did say
that I mean it yeah I'm just warning you
no I don't think you're giving those
little guys enough credit because from
their point of view youth sociology is
everywhere all our bodies are you social
group so that's another important point
I what are the main things that you do
bring it up all I have to do you know
with why it's important to understand
the relation between individual level
selection and group selection and why
it's so seldom that we get group
selection managing in the face of
normally overpowering individual flexion
applies certainly to the origin of the
levels of biological organization you
know the origin of the eukaryotic cell
to start with a long time the origin of
multicellular organism long time you'd
think it was sort of a logical step if
you were an engineer and designing it
but when it has to be done by natural
selection with all that competition
between the two levels of selection and
ambiguities and so on then maybe the
slow pace of major level evolution makes
more sense yes thanks for asking a
question okay simple as that
thank you all very much thank you all
very much for coming thank you to
Professor Wilson certainly he is someone
who not only stands on the shoulders of
giants but hopefully everyone in this
room will start standing on his
shoulders thanks very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]